in the lobby of financial peace Plaza
Cynthia is with us hey Cynthia how are
you really good thing good it's so good
to have you where do you live
we leave in Greenville South Carolina
very cool and you're here to do your
debt-free scream yes sir awesome and
who's with you or these three three
cherubs with you they are my kids
gets outta here thirteen I six seven and
little Ethan he's four all right very
cool so how much debt have you paid off
Cynthia sixty thousand dollars and how
long did that take you twenty two months
sir twenty two months making what kind
of money during that time 50,000 50,000
so tell me the story what happened and
how what started twenty two months ago
twenty two months ago December the 4th
2012 my husband Dennis sparks Hill
passed away oh my goodness what happened
he had a stroke and before that he we
listen to you every day he listened to
you every day when I was with him you
know in the car and whatever we were
listening to you and how old was he he
was 29 years old and what 29 29 29 years
old yes sir and he he was a really
really awesome guy and he was always
finding ways to provide for his family a
hard worker
really nice work ethic great father
awesome husband and he wanted to leave a
legacy for his kids unfortunately the
time just we never know when this is
gonna happen to any of us right so 22 I
liked the two years ago I right after he
passed away I just set the goal for me
and the kids to be debt-free and today
we are here we paid off the house after
22 months - yes sir we we have no left
unbelievable you know I am I am
garden aid and we were living off of
16,000 a year we I got my notes here
okay we right after Dennis passed away
like our lifestyle really didn't change
because you know he was really good with
money and he just knew where every every
penny went and we but after he passed
away you know the things that I did
differently to make this happen we cut
the cable off we got the internet off we
turned the power off we well my cell
phone plan I just said goodbye to them
and I got the cheapest phone that I
could pay for and it was with prepaid
cards we went to thrift shops you know
after it like when is when the kids say
go to school you know before they go to
school you pay you but you can spend a
lot of money if you go to the mall and
or not even the ball just purchase brand
new we want to trade shops and we never
purchased anything new at all we went to
yard sales we didn't eat out nothing
that we purchase was brand new and I try
to do couponing for a while but I didn't
have really much time so I just couldn't
do it in two years you paid off your
house yes sir that was the dream it was
a dream
Dennis's and mine to make this happen
and and God is really good I I just
thank him every day and count my
blessings every day for his mercy and
for being our provider provider and our
protector after my husband passed away
anywhere before and he was always
watching over us but I just want to
mention mention for everybody that is
out there that they think that they
cannot do this and if they set a goal
and if they put their mind into it
it's gonna happen it doesn't matter what
people what people tells you I don't
know how many people make fun of me and
I didn't care but you have a goal and
you just look forward and you go and you
go and finally it's unbelievable when it
finally happens Wow
so kids I think if you look around
behind your mom's back you're gonna see
a superwoman cape oh my gosh you are
something else get out my husband I'm
sure he was but you're amazing and it
was like I said it was our dream well
it's not it's not the biggest house
actually it's a paid-for house paper
house but my husband like I said he he
watch where every penny went and so
what's it worth about it was it is
fourth 109,000 allowed but he when we
purchase the house will be well after we
have Greenville South Carolina $109,000
house is not a bad house no no I'm
blessed like I said you know but but he
like he when we we were seeking for a
house and and we didn't even look at the
house the inside he just saw the the
sign of how much the house cost and when
he looked at it he's like this is the
house we are gonna buy this is her house
that was like it can't even look at
things and but you know it was it is
some first house and I'm just grateful
hole dirt how old are you I'm well I'm
31 now all right yeah so impressive oh
thank you I mean you know the the things
you learn when you go through stuff like
you guys have gone through as a family
make the rest of life beautiful it is
beautiful so we enjoyed every minimum
things together you know my my
little guy here he like almost like
three times a week we have our family
time that's how he calls it you know and
we just celebrate life because we never
know when is gonna be the time to its
precious we're just here is precious and
I'm just just so thankful for my husband
because he introduced me to you and I
didn't go to the to the to the classes
that you provide everything was the
radio but you can learn a lot from what
you hear and I'm just grateful and I
thank you I have a little list of the
photo that I want to thank I want to
thank my mother and the Moro family
Laurie Covington and if holiday for the
emotional support I would like to thank
you grandma and grandpa Barksdale for
being good grandparents really nice
grandparents for my kids
and I'm just I just this is a dream come
true
you're amazing well you have inspired
people all over America I am finally
here and telling your story you are
something else thank you I just cannot
believe I'm leaving a dream the dream
that my husband and I dream for a long
time mm you can do this you can do
anything I mean you get you make sixty
thousand dollars a year you don't have
any payment no I may you may be getting
raised when you get home I don't know
you can I mean you guys will be able to
do anything you want to do and and the
the the the this whole process what it's
done for you for your confidence for
your family for these kids they walk
this out with you they're changed
forever - it's unbelievable
you guys are so inspiring thank you now
I also I want to thank last but not
least my children for being a really
good team yeah yeah they are a good team
okay yeah you can tell by watching them
pretty cool stuff I love it all right
kids you guys have been practicing the
debt free Scream team all right all
right well this is about the best one
I've had in a while I'll tell you that
so all right Cynthia count it down
$60,000 paid off house and everything in
22 months
let's hear a debt free scream all right
ready three two one
oh my gosh Wow oh man oh man thank you
Lord for work that matters Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
man Wow can I talk to you while ago I
didn't even know the story and then you
could be on the air make me proud like a
kid a good debt free scream dude well
done thank you we'll get letters about
that for a year that's amazing well if
you want to go through a few you're
going through on a ship y'all like to do
that or anything you want
[Music]